so this sample it's a very very
interesting sample it's arsenic this is
a juror of liquid nitrogen and you can
see that the nitrogen is evaporating
from the top of Britain the pourer
stands for per borate and the s-silly
spans for silicate
or can you come out one of my colleagues
used to work with it described it as
evil the phosphorus is oxidized in the
air to generate a note P for phosphorus
because it has a coating of oxide on the
surface now it's packed in argon because
our gun is very very inert it doesn't
react with anything ever since this and
get quite excited I can see lots and
lots of lines in the blue and the green
region and these are all specific to the
individual atoms this one just has more
data than you could possibly want see
the different grain sizes
and you can imagine the periodic table
bit like the family photograph who and
there she blows
you